faire son sac pour partir en week end
cela fait bien longtemps que dany n'a
pas fait ses gestes
aujourd'hui est un jour particulier elle
part à saint gilles pour deux jours avec
son mari
c'était dans familiale s'occupe
quotidiennement de sa belle mère âgée de
88 ans et de sa belle soeur en situation
de handicap
c'est les préparatifs on m'appelle quoi
en tout cas la saint-gilles passagers de
l'allemagne plutôt des trucs d'été à je
pensais des t-shirts ou des shorts et
maillots de bain surtout et devez savoir
pour pouvoir marcher un petit peu sur la
plage se détendre vraiment quand je
m'occupe de marie-claude ça fait deux
ans après une trisomie 21 est aussi
marie claude et ma belle soeur et de ma
belle mère âgée de 88 ans
si elle est soutenue dans la journée par
une auxiliaire de vie et l'infirmière
qui passe régulièrement pour administrer
les médicaments de sa belle-mère danny
se retrouve seul le soir avec son mari à
gérer la nuit des deux aînés qui vivent
avec elle parce est 17h basse et moi
c'est moi surtout pour marie-claude
parce que bon les nuits des fois elle se
révèle n'est pas bien il faut s'en
occuper il faut pas attendre seulement
la relève du lendemain pour par exemple
s'il faut laver la nuit s'il faut être
avec quelle moi j'attends pas la relève
du lendemain coin marie-claude dont la
santé a périclité ces deux dernières
années nécessite une présence constante
c'est physiquement et moralement parce
que bambins il faut s'occuper de
marie-claude surtout parce que marie
claude
elle elle ne sait pas dire par exemple
quand elle est malade elle n'arrive pas
à s'exprimer nous montrer où elle a mal
donc il faut qu'on devine il faut qu'on
concis si on trouve pas vraiment ce
qu'est la ont fait appel aux médecins
mais au quotidien avec elle c'est c'est
vraiment fatiguant pour venir en aide
aux aidants et leur permettre de prendre
un peu de temps pour eux le conseil
départemental a mis en place le répit
repos il s'agit pour l'aider de
bénéficier de 3 jours de repos dans une
structure appartenant à la collectivité
toute personne a besoin de ça toute
personne a besoin d'un moment a eu
vraiment et ça serait pire au pôle à
nous on nous permet ça donc c'est
vraiment bien pour nous dany a choisi la
formule week-end avec son mari elle va
se reposer au village corail comme les
médicaments surtout parce que je pars en
week est donc il faut que ça soit sur
ces médicaments seront de bras panon à
la saline les bains
nous sommes ici au village corail c'est
dans ce cadre à quelques mètres de la
plage qui gagne et son mari vont passer
un moment à dieu merci je vais demander
au lieu d'adapter et de signer ce
nouveau contrat quand sa participation à
elle donc sur le biais du gps apc 18
euros et 300 kg et donc ce soir on
commencerait le dîner avec 19 30 le
petit déjeuner le matin donc entre 7h et
à d'accord 2010 à midi le soir 19h30 un
accueil chaleureux qui donne le ton du
week end destination la rivière des
marsouins du moins le bungalow qui porte
maintenant à l'arrivée ça y est un super
week-end les affaires arriveront un peu
plus tard en attendant on découvre les
lieux et surtout
heureusement on se sent bien bien bien
bien et surtout je pense
on va se reposer vraiment gras c'est
tout cas c'est très calme
c'était accueillant aussi voilà comme on
dépayse là l'arrivée s'est bien passé
tout s'est joué très bien très bien très
bien passé le personnel est très gentil
jusqu'à maintenant on a à la réception
très bien on va quitter la maison et ils
auront ce soir
le pam 0 dernier à pouvoir keller manger
pour m accueille ce soir l année encore
cette date aux aguets pour écouter si
les codes et répète à nice et la main ou
pas we can prône au repos total donc cet
homme plus d'inquiétude plus
d'obligations du temps pour se reposer
et profiter l'un de l'autre
le répit rupo une formule qui a permis à
plus de 20000 aidant de prendre un peu
de temps
en oubliant la lourdeur de leur
quotidien
le gps ap groupement d'intérêt public
services à la personne a mis en place
depuis 2012
un dispositif en faveur des aidants
familiaux que c'est un dispositif qui
vient répondre aux problématiques
d'épuisement et d'accompagnement des
aidants dans le rôle quotidien 5000
personnes ont bénéficié de ce dispositif
plus de soixante mille heures de
remplacement ont été réalisées au
domicile des aidants flamme hausse de
11,7 une grosse que d'aucuns peuvent
bénéficier donc les aidants familiaux
pour pouvoir être remplacées au domicile
par des professionnels de l'aide à
domicile et plus de 900 séjour ont été
délivrés sur le séjour grand-air le
séjour en terre ce sont donc des séjours
de courte durée que peuvent aussi
bénéficier les aidants familiaux donc
des saisons qui ce qu'ils peuvent être
donc être effectués donc au village
corail donc à saint gilles est également
donc à cilaos particularité donc du
séjour à cilaos les aidants peuvent
bénéficier d'une prestation thermale à
l'établissement irene à bourg pour
pouvoir bénéficier du dispositif
il faut donc appeler un numéro vert le 0
800 500 30 00 2 donc à la suite de cet
appel
une infirmière dont prendra au contact
avec
didon il viendra faire donc une
évaluation et lui proposera donc les
prestations les plus adaptées à sa
situation